interview mardi logis
alors moi je vois que la france sera pas
championne du monde se connaît pas la
date
il faut décider de l'alsace bossue des
dates ça se mange pas de date mon choix
il faut une date précise mais je ne vais
pas malheureusement c'est ça le problème
ah oui c'est qu'on n'a pas la date donc
vous n'avez pas pouvoir nous dire là bas
non parce que si vous me donniez une
date peu voilà le thème de la france et
le 20 juin 20 juin alors ça c'est les
horaires des trains non sens sur les
positions des places des plats nef le 20
juin c'est pas mauvais à l'esade le 21
ça serait mieux je suis aujourd'hui ça
serait mieux si ça se passait autour du
24 là je dirai où l'on va appeler le
responsable en juillet vous jugez vous
voyez juillet veut garder vivant le 14
ou pas
on appellera baffie incendies en corse
moi j'ai giboulet pour mars et beaucoup
de cadeaux à noël
l'histoire du cpe là il va y avoir des
retombées tous à début mai fin avril la
halle c'est pas fini je pense on se
penche chirac se représentera ou pas moi
je crois pas je pense pas non plus un
non sens qu'on est d'accord
oui bien voilà tout le monde est
d'accord la clairvoyance et pas de la
voyance mais j'essaye tu vois jamais
elle aussi vaillant chaîne les
socialistes vont se tirer dans les
pattes à l'automne enfin ça c'est
certain de toute façon là ils reprennent
du poil de la bête
extra l'image des jeux sans même des
feuilles mortes au début mais la
rencontre
gdp cela au sérieux oui oui d'accord
avec ça oui tout à fait bien
s'enregistrer
c'est à dire que après ont diffusé lundi
envers moi je fais moi qui aura du monde
sur le périph demain à 19 heures des
trucs en énorme et moi j'ai tout noté et
on fera comme avec vous ouais c'est bien
la prochaine fois vous venez on regarde
witsel a bon pour une fois devrait pas
trop tarder on n'ira que ça va pas
s'arranger
moi ce que je vois c'est pas eux non moi
dans les bijoux conçus en revanche c'est
que j'avais donné une interview à métro
où j'habite
j'avais fait le thème de ma roue mais
jean lyall iranien oh la la
ah ouais alors lui je vais vous dire
j'ai une trouille bleue de ce type
il a un thème diabolique diabolique
il est scorpion aux lions bon il est la
nuit noire et or à nu sur son soleil si
je me sens bien
il ya des trucs très très dur et je
pense qu'il est non pour détruire et
c'est ça qui fait peur et j'avais écrit
qu entre le 25 février et le 25 avril
il allait se passer quelque chose un
rapport à l'iran et regardez là la
raison annoncé que j'allais faire une
fois de plus j'ai très très peur je vois
que tu vois la moelle et même pas partie
j'ai un voyant qu'ils déconnent dans ma
bagnole des patins huit jours
c'est le double du cygne à l'huile ou
pas assez tôt
tiens est ce qu'il ya des manifs en
france qu'on me suis dit oh non
si si il y aurait des manifs en juillet
en août bah écoutez c'est incroyable
alors alors qu'est-ce que j'ai marqué
jan fabre en vacances j'ai marqué non ça
c'est un désaccord des poireaux fin juin
début juillet c'est possible ça que je
trouvais génial car il n'a pas la fin je
vois ça déjà c'est le message
moi je l'avais trouvée à mener sans
phase on est en fait c'est ici que je me
calme incroyable chez nous dans les bois
exactement les mêmes les mêmes
prévisions et vise avec le groupe le
marché bien là je suis très embêté parce
que j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle
quelle nouvelle je prévois qu'un acteur
célèbre très aimé du public mourra avant
le mois de septembre mais français
français battus tout fait très aimé très
ému réseau n'est pas correct c'est trop
long et trop vague
il faut dire quel jour on peut dire que
c'est des trucs comme ça donc les mac
jeudi quand les est mort d'artistes
comme ça et c'est moi je peux battre
nicolas sarkozy prendra ses distances
avec le gouvernement prendra ses
distances à la rentrée bon bah non non
je parle au nom
moi je crois pas non maintenant au
contraire il est il est dans une passe
difficile là
il va avoir un moment encore difficile
jusque le mois de juin pour lui ça va
pas être facile
voilà voilà une prévision voilà on lui
le soutien moi j'avais dit qui
professionnalise enoctobre juin début
juillet pas bon oui mais après quand
jupiter justement va être en sagittaire
pour lui et pour tout les verso de la
fin janvier ce sera excellent c'est à
dire à la fin de l'année 2006 là et vous
pensez que ségolène va le battre en 2007
elle a des étoiles fantastique l'année
prochaine voyez c'est marrant moi ça on
est d'accord encore une fois let's non
mais attends meilleur que maintenant
encore meilleure au lot tolède a essayé
dans la région parisienne pour voir ça
s'apprend la meilleure matante le
commettre est-ce que ça 80 ou l'allemand
est ce que ça sera suffisamment
important pour subjuguer la france
complètement et voilà de tension des
élections bon si elle a en face d'elle
sarkozy qui a également des étoiles
assez intéressant trek avait donc bien
bloqué la paie des toiles que l'autre il
faut que je j'ai pas été analysé en
détail en quoi suis convaincu à notre
site ou son chat était convaincu la dent
mais là que tu reconnais que mais bien
sûr je reconnais traîneau mais j'avais
quant aux rennais
oh
les corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus